the founder of The Oath Keepers militia
group is headed to prison for more than
18 years that is the most of any January
6th defendant so far Stuart Rhodes is
his name he was convicted of seditious
conspiracy and other charges and he told
the judge when given the opportunity to
speak yesterday quote my only crime is
opposing those who are destroying our
country close close Scott McFarland is
at The District Courthouse in Washington
with the response from the judge in this
case who noted that Rhodes showed no
remorse and is in his opinion an ongoing
threat to the fabric of the country
Scott good morning
yeah Tony the judge called Rhodes a
threat to democracy and then in a moment
that seemed to freeze and silence the
courtroom he said there's fear of
violence after the next election
more than 1 000 people have been charged
for the capital Insurrection but former
military service member Yale law school
grad and founder of the far right Oath
Keepers Stuart Rhodes has now been
handed the toughest sentence to date
he was convicted a trial of conspiring
to block the peaceful transfer of power
through force and of planning in advance
prosecutors cited these remarks from
2020. we have men already stationed
outside D.C as a nuclear option in case
the attempt to remove the president
illegally we will step in and stop it
the flight's coming roads will remain
Behind Bars until nearly 20 40 after the
judge allowed a sentencing enhancement
for terrorism that's not only the
longest sentence by a good amount but it
was backed up by the court saying you
sir present a threat to the fabric of
democracy prosecutors argued Rhodes and
his co-conspirators raised money readied
military gear even staged guns nearby in
Virginia in case then president Trump
invoked the Insurrection act which
Rhodes urged in an open letter to Trump
before January 6. Rhodes was
Unapologetic in court calling himself a
political prisoner and say The Oath
Keepers were quiet professionals
unfairly targeted for supporting Donald
Trump his defense attorneys say Rhodes
will appeal there's no way that he was
the leader of the director of what
happened on January 6th he was just a
convenient Target but federal judge Amit
Meda made his view clear calling roads a
danger to U.S democracy and added we all
now hold our Collective breaths with an
election approaching will we have
another January 6th that remains to be
seen
the same judge yesterday sentenced
Rhodes's co-defendant Florida Oath
Keepers leader Kelly Meigs to 12 years
in prison which lays down a marker as
proud boys face sentencing for seditious
conspiracy in late August Nate
Uriah Scott seems like a message is
being delivered with these sentences
handed down thank you